[Aplausos]
que grande responsabilidade de
representar confirmou o seu constituinte
que em público pensar aí é muito difícil
agradeço as novas denúncias mas você
interesse o poço tem estas três
quadrilhas tudo ou nada
é como se nós fôssemos generais num
campo de batalha queremos decidir
qualquer coisa de repente duas juntas
forte e violenta palavra tudo tudo 15
proteja e parece somos poderosos o
suficiente para ter inteligência para
ocuparmos de tutor e somos sofisticado
sociedade é compreendermos o significado
da outra palavrinha tá nada prevê que o
time está em má notícia para o nosso
sábado 14 uma vez e é esta nós não temos
recursos produtivos para pensar o diabo
de tudo e pensar o diabo nada
nós não sabemos quais são os diferentes
dessas duas quadrilhas de 13 pereira que
lançava foi tão fácil proferidas em
público o que significam
nós vimos estas pedras número final do
respeito dos dias teremos novidades um
privilégio de viver
nós somos generais em um campo de
batalha chamado viva e podemos escolher
tudo ou nada mas quem se mantém ser tudo
é uma grande mentira
nada é uma outra grande mentira estamos
desde as mentiras simplesmente eles
dizem muito sobre nós é como se eu doei
ficássemos na nossa vida é pequenininha
liliputiana de repente podemos conseguir
qualquer coisa que palavras do português
antigo que qualquer coisa que o
momentoso a e criticamente o enigma está
precisamente no maior perigo só com 283
ou alegria ou o que acontece
ninguém parece que distribuímos qualquer
coisa é uma coisa outra tanto faz
qualquer que seja o contexto voto
seguida por churrasco que estava ouvindo
812 decidir qualquer coisa nós somos
pessoas do ou podemos decidir qualquer
coisa seja coisas do cotidiano chechênia
mais significado teológico de vestir e
quando caminhamos pelas ruas dos nossos
filiados
tudo parece um exemplo feito nesta
grande cidade de siriri qualquer produto
comercial
eu posso escolher o centro da turquia tu
é que és
nós temos esta obsessão de tal forma de
tal forma no nosso interior ressalta que
parece que nem conseguimos olhar a vida
de outra forma os nossos contemporâneos
sobre sobre o ambiente sombrio sobre
sobre as contas da silva seguir tudo o
que queremos é forma de sair da china
sobre os eventos que queremos ter uma
palavra a opção é tão grave desde o
espaço em seus pés
temos amigos do planeta terra
nós podemos perceber tudo alguns
território impossível do passado da
história oferecer o que aconteceu grande
violência e aos pedem desculpa
os assuntos estão duas entradas por zeus
ainda que eles têm sobre o assunto
nós somos super decisões que eu pensava
como se chamava não é porque eu sou o
homem da zona jogos nem dois mas que o
texto sobre tudo e sobre nada
nós nunca fizemos absolutamente nada
não temos esse privilégio que temos tudo
à nossa volta de força essa convicção
escutei coisas tão fundamentalmente
errada o que manuela o que isto é uma
luta pra verificar é de cinza o mais
banal do nosso cotidiano
eu não sei qual foi a cena mais banal
estou feliz em ir ao supermercado
comprar ti quarta vez de grupos
vamos ao supermercado e chegamos no jogo
que tem muitas marcas durante aquelas
marcas que qualquer coisa dentro nós
disso temos que ir com esta margem
coloquial a marca e nós temos um olhar
para todas elas queremos olhar que
ficamos olhar que temos olharem a china
espera que qualquer coisa que aconteça
dentro nós uma film market uma essência
é 11 os visito o surge a certa altura
como se fosse um dos seus muitos sociais
devemos atuar só pode ser isso aí
devemos nem aquela pasta 200 porque eles
não querem ir embora e aconteceu um
sério e nós soluções duas tarefas que
nos deparámos que qualquer coisa de
menino mimado que aconteceu e está
acontecendo dessa forma
dessa forma daniel porque quer dizer o
que ele tem por exemplo isso acontece
também no nível do muro
estávamos eu tratava o nosso dinheirinho
é e do peru que deixam os olhos
vermelhos em alguma cena bonita
nós fomos determinados misteriosa
isso acontece com as nossas emoções que
acontece com as nossas compras no
supermercado por exemplo jogar muito
para nos deitarmos realizado na nossa
terrinha é muito conforto e de repente
de 70 058 copa do mundo vai nos 1 sonha
ninguém aqui dentro do serviço eu tenho
que não foi do pt ela eu quero hoje já
postamos jaíton eu quero hoje sonhara
olha é frequente do time já que o script
que um dia é um homem rico índia que faz
notar se a si próprio é inconveniente um
montinho de uma forma aspire persisto
mais banal dos sonhos porque conversa
estava obsoleto zona e de repente somos
visitados pelo nosso sonho é ver com as
nossas emoções que eu tenho a ver com
dizem os seguintes muito sofisticados
que tem no nosso profeta e decretou a
virada
escritores enfrentam isto fosse
investido nisso eu quero ninguém
consegue é o que eu lembro é o que
espero que qualquer coisa aconteça
daí achei me no entanto a cultura
contemporânea é culpa não é nossa
os nossos pais fundadores do início da
retirada organizou não seria dessa forma
disseram-nos vezes sem conta tudo sido
expostos no centro do palco tom e médias
é como se fosse um fantasma só quero
todo mundo da nossa vida nós já temos
experiência suficiente
nós gostaríamos de ver bem as coisas
porque porque porque porque o que
acontece conosco que teríamos de
compreender porque eu estou no sábado
porque está comigo há muito tempo eu
gostava de jogar aqui no botão desligar
não não estou idéias sem fundamento é um
desenho na lógica de festas como o de
sérgio manoel
estas visitas tinha idéias das emoções
desde os sonhos que estas não sei o que
está longe
ninguém falou sobre isso queria lhe além
do cruzeiro qualquer hora
e quero colocar as minhas pernas numa
rua de pirata era só espero que não
venha eu vou
neste centro ou eu vou me sinto com o
tom
espero que qualquer coisa que aconteça o
filme sobre o exame
eu tenho esse pensamento do rio se tudo
tudo o que tornava a monstruosa que tudo
no nosso cotidiano e se use por dia aos
seis minutos teve uma reação
estamos sempre seria conseguir colocar o
meu perfil de sua obra
eu sou tão bom eu mereço o prêmio nobel
maior capaz de colocar o braço direito
do outro lado está um pouquinho de ser
visto
nós não temos 50 todos os cinco minutos
que nós vemos um minuto se estávamos
antes de qualquer coisa eu digo isto
pode colocar eu vou por ele como popular
vai ser este gesto vai ser este gesto
que estamos sempre olhando esperando nós
cotidianos que nossa vida e parece nos
que é um assunto grande é tua ajuda de
uma aranha é isso que o brinquedo minuto
em que descubro que estamos a decidir
qualquer coisa menos 3.000 inteiro
espera entregar aí o do sábado à tarde
tudo o evento irá novamente ele me
ajudou maiô ou o homem especialmente
mentirosa
se tudo isto tiver alguma ser dada à
procura de nada porque ele é também não
vai ser tua começou a escrever ideias
nunca são nossas
os corpos de gênio operacional seus dias
interpretações sem que nos aconteceu
subsidiados 200 objetivos especiais que
compreendemos o país sessões
tudo isso de ver algum método remota
muito remota e que não significará que
boa parte dos pilares conceptuais com
que organizamos a nossa vida são muito
frágeis e é excelente pois nós não
conseguimos viver a idéia de autonomia
a ideia de ciência e exige
responsabilidade
se isto é assim como é que podemos
recusar algum criminoso ou de ter tido o
elevado privilégio de ter contido o seu
quinzinho e não têm de ser
responsabilizados eu fui visitado por
uma emoção especial não importa é ter
uma visão das coisas
ele tem teria gostado que tenho
percebido de outra forma
isso isso não vai acontecer eu imaginei
que seria nossos filiados à iaaf
consolidada em exercício na bola aérea o
império eo uso
nós absolutamente vivente ilusoriamente
evidente que tudo aquilo que é o
resultado das nossas decisões porque o
assunto é a aranha super trunfo clinton
que não diz muito pequeninos é que
tomamos decisões
tudo isso vai acrescentar é durante os
séculos cultura - iremos para a cultura
humana e sentimos que há um progresso
esta nunca houve progresso na unidade
nós gostamos tanto da ilusão do
progresso
reparem no livro mais velho da nossa
terra o irmão mais velho da nossa terra
são os poemas homéricos ainda no dia de
ontem saiu representam suas com nós a
mais de três milênios por que é que o
bardo por exemplo os cursos de quilos no
quinto salto de olinda e isso que as
pessoas que eu tenha a frente é que irão
ensinar
nós também vivemos ensinados que naquela
época havia exércitos
nós também temos exército tem aquela
época em seu juízo tribunais nós
continuamos e ter juízo
tem aquela época as pessoas gostavam de
vinho e do mel
nós confiamos no estadual com cinco
coisas dos crimes
a organizada há mais de 3 mil anos e é
exatamente igual a nós não
também nada nem nunca iremos o que falta
o estudo foi coordenado por qualquer
coisa que tenha a ver com aquilo que os
visitantes vão ser disso uma decisão
você disse uma agulha fica apaixonado
torcedor isso é um conceito burro com o
serviço o encontro criativo
nós só temos imagens imagens
hoje estamos então que tal forma que nós
podemos comparar os livros mais velhos
da nossa terra com vossa própria vida e
dizer 'não outro desce 1
parece que os progressos fatal aconteceu
mas gostamos de inflacionária diferença
nós devemos nos pequenos detalhes e
tiveram os botos
os portões da nossa vida e dizemos
coisas explicou mas como o manual é isso
que encontramos em león no estilo muitos
clínicos esquecer os que é que recebemos
é mais elas ou elas não compensa é
aquilo que nós não sabemos que o seguiam
com estas lesões e más notícias se
inicie nada de uma ciência
deixa eu terminar a refeição com um mas
se tudo isto que eu quero dizer é pensar
nessas coisas
tivemos mesmo fato não seremos o que
significa que ninguém
significa que significa que desisti do
povo significa significa temos vidas
dizendo que estava emoções emprestadas
idéias em como sair de recorrer como se
fosse um filme em nossa cabeça tudo isso
muito emprestado
ninguém deseja
nada nem ninguém pensa nada com esta
união não pode ter um fato ninguém sente
que as pessoas não saibam da tarde ligas
eu tenho que dizer o que quer dizer não
pode ser salvar todo o povo somos surdos
de vida em buscadas tudo em bom estado
isso faz mexer o pensamento terrível ver
se vale a pena continuarem o empréstimo
é uma alegria final tudo este povo chato
o evento manoel
nós não temos um minuto nós não temos um
segundo docente na área decidir qualquer
coisa é frágil o gesto o ciclo vai
colocar as pernas tanto faz
antes de qualquer coisa isto se
generalizar mas é como se a matéria
prima do nosso universo não fosse aquela
que os nossos cientistas britânicos
dizem que é ato o chefe veículos micro
físicas leis da natureza
nós somos e matéria prima das coisas e
quando decidimos que com seu universo
estivessem construídos em três nós somos
as portas da cidade aqui razões era
teremos andria universo do crime
acontecer poderia criar moda não poderia
criar um pensamento não queria criar
grande estrutura com estas três amigos
todos muito bem ser desprovida de
fundamento
tudo isto pode ser falso que deixou o
território tomado
olha tu acabas te dizer qualquer coisa
estas pessoas eu fosse o autor de
sugestões e destas idéias que os amigos
se alguém diferente do pensamento e
dentro dele escondido entre as duas
orelhas
não sinto muito especial situada entre
unidade eu tenho que dizer sim ou não
essas palavras não são minhas são
aqueles que visitaram foram aquelas que
acontecerá então obrigado pela vossa
atenção